the only thing Americans love more than
cars is modifying their cars in
completely illegal ways now this is
America so let's start with guns now
this is a Polish military vehicle but
plenty of Americans see this and think
yeah that's exactly the car I need to
head over to Walmart now honestly I
think this is probably what F1 needs in
the next season but there are times when
having a gun mounted inside or outside
of a vehicle might come in handy like
when you're Nick Fury and you need to
evade a SWAT team or if you're James
Bond
or when you're trying to get around the
idiots in the DC trucker Convoy now
obviously it's pretty much indisputable
that this looks really cool but it's
obviously illegal to mount a gun to your
car right it's not like you can go on
Amazon and buy a rack that lets you put
a gun on your actual car
well there are actually lots of
different gun mounts for sale on Amazon
that you can put on your car like this
Vulcan Quick Draw magnetic High grip
handgun Mount holster which clamps to
your car of your desk wall basically
anywhere you think you might want to
Quick Draw a handgun from and here's a
magnetic car gun mount for just 29.99
now are any of these products legal well
some of them are it's generally legal to
install something that lets you mount a
weapon to your vehicle or other surface
but once you've actually installed a
loaded weapon it's more likely to be
completely illegal so let me break this
down first of all in some states you
need a license to carry concealed weapon
so in those States driving with a
concealed weapon would be illegal unless
you are licensed now what about mounting
a long gun to the car
not surprisingly not legal in
Pennsylvania for example no person even
a holder of a license to carry a firearm
may carry a loaded long gun in a vehicle
and you also can't get around the law by
switching to an ATV or snowmobile either
since it's generally unlawful to operate
or ride any snowmobile or ATV in
possession of a loaded firearm now what
about non-working firearms for show now
in some states you might be able to get
away with displaying a dummy firearm in
a vehicle this is common for World War
II reenactors who use decommissioned
military transport vehicles and weapons
from that era however you should not
assume that inoperable weapons are legal
brandishing an imitation or dummy
firearm is a crime in California but
then what about the old private land
loophole now it might be possible for
you to mount a 50 caliber machine gun on
a Jeep if you have the money and fire it
on private land in a state with few gun
laws but if you drive around the
neighborhood with it even in a gun
friendly State you risk being arrested
for a whole multitude of different laws
violating brandishing laws and serving
the peace
perceived threatening of other people
and you know driving around in a weapon
of War generally framed upon by many
different jurisdictions even if you're
James Bond but maybe guns per se aren't
your thing what if you wanted to turn
your car into a flamethrower
well a lot of people have surprisingly
had this idea in the 1990s South African
invented flamethrower called a blaster
that was mounted to the car's
undercarriage the Blaster was meant to
deter carjackings by burning anyone who
attempted it and as you can see it
definitely had the capability of
barbecuing a human now it did not go
over particularly well and the cost of
the modification was so high that only a
few hundred were sold still that's a few
hundred of modification that could turn
your car into a human barbecuer but what
about in the good old us of a can you
put a flamethrower on the undercarriage
of your car well basically no because as
I explained in a recent video
flamethrowers aren't totally legal and
you have the right to own one as an
American you can have a flamethrower on
your private property but modifications
to a car or a truck are different so
let's look at the kits that modify your
exhaust to shoot Flames Amazon sells
them you can buy older ones on eBay not
that you should if you did the Hot Licks
exhaust kits have a lifetime warranty so
is this legal absolutely absolutely not
if you try this in Virginia the state
can throw you in jail and suspend your
driver's license for six months a lot of
States including Virginia have specific
laws that prohibit devices for the
emission of smoke screens gas projectors
or flame throwers which are prohibited
in that state that means that if you do
anything to modify your muffler so that
smoke or flame shootout you could be
charged with a felony and once you start
meddling with systems that control
emissions that runs a foul of
environmental regulations now if you've
ever been to a people competition you've
probably witnessed coal rolling now at
these competitions modified trucks and
tractors drag a metal sled filled with a
way to cross the course and the point is
to determine which vehicle is capable of
dragging the heaviest weight over the
longest distance but see all that smoke
some people have started what's called
rolling coal on their own Vehicles some
guys with diesel pickup trucks have
modified their trucks to blow coal at
people who drive electric cars and this
modification allows the driver to flip a
switch that spews a billow of dirty coal
smoke out of the exhaust there are
videos of this all over YouTube of
truckers rolling coal in the faces of
protesters cyclists and Runners and the
practice has got more attention when
Texas teens flooded a restaurant with
coal smoke the video became a hit on
Tick Tock and now many states make this
explicitly illegal though it was
probably already illegal under general
laws of applicability Maryland outright
bandit in 2017. and in the states that
don't specifically prohibit it it's
probably still illegal you can get in
big trouble because shooting a plume of
coal smoke is number one inherently
dangerous and and it's tied to other
crimes for example a 16 year old Texas
boy driving a diesel pickup thought it
would be funny to blow coal at eight
cyclists when he got close to them he
hit six of them with his truck he was
charged with six counts of felony
aggravated assault with a deadly weapon
and rolling coal requires a driver to
have overridden or tampered with the
vehicle's emission controls and
tampering with those emission control
systems is blatantly illegal under the
Clean Air Act and additionally
intentionally blowing a huge plume of
black smoke at other people almost
certainly qualifies as assault and
battery may be a public nuisance as well
so just because there's not a specific
regulation on this it's still probably
incredibly illegal and of course rolling
Cole is not the only illegal
modification to your exhaust a lot of
people have installed what are called
exhaust cutouts which allows you to
completely bypass your catalytic
converter and your muffler to run
basically a straight exhaust at the
touch of a button and if you're talking
about illegal car products you have to
talk to The Experts like my friends over
at donut media James and Jerry you say
friends I say clients
I see the whole world
uh you guys went to the trouble of
actually buying a whole bunch of these
mythical illegal car products uh how did
you get your hands on some of this stuff
well apparently even though this stuff
is technically illegal you can still
purchase quite a bit of it on Amazon and
if you can't find it on Amazon then you
can definitely get it on eBay
it's not illegal to buy just illegal to
use you know I mean according to You
Like a Knife so uh uh you know on your
channel we talked about some of these
products we went through some of the
most illegal products you can possibly
buy over on donor media so be sure to
check out that video but let's talk
about some of the things that you have
here uh let's see the first one here is
a a license plate cover uh this thing
has a shade that comes down so this is a
remote controlled uh license plate cover
like you said it has a little curtain
you hit a button and it completely hides
your license plate from whoever uh likes
to look at license plates they're doing
car pranks yeah totally yeah and they're
not the police yeah
yeah for use in car pranks or you don't
want people taking pictures of your car
exposing your license plate yeah so the
hit of a button Zoom you can't even see
it yeah I assume that this is very very
illegal incredibly illegal uh there's
just no way around it that's not
surprisingly you can't obstruct the
police from viewing your your license
plate one might call that obstruction of
justice really is it really well it
could be it could be wow it could be
that's more serious than I thought
that's like what Senators do
you guys were you guys are fancy like
Senators yeah fancy Senator crimes nice
and then we have you got an honest to
goodness radar jammer yeah this is a
Jammer so it not only detects but it
jams the signal coming off a policeman's
radar gun yeah and and the instructions
to this thing say that if you go through
a place where it's illegal just turn it
off yeah just turn it off and then it's
fine I guess but there's a number of
states listed in the pamphlet that came
with this uh that it is illegal in
including California where we are right
now I think that is under inclusive I
think that's only a handful of the
states where it's actually illegal yeah
uh it also has some really
I don't want to call it inaccurate but I
just don't trust the engineering that
went into it because it says it doesn't
transmit anything at all yeah because
apparent I guess if it does transmit
stuff then that's what makes for sure
illegal but it doesn't transmit stuff it
uses the police
beam takes it takes that police beam and
it uses mirrors to send that beat back
to them so that they uh it scrambles it
but it doesn't produce a scrambling
signal itself apparently apparently
apparently call me call me skeptical on
that yeah and then you have a whole
variety of things that help you not
impersonate the police yeah so right
here we have uh flashing red and blue
lights just red and blue just red and
blue yeah uh very illegal obviously and
then very illegal on its own but then
when you pair it with
[Music]
um
[Music]
that is so loud it's hard to
overestimate how loud that thing is yeah
and if you see someone pull up behind
you with flashing blue and red lights
and you hear
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
I mean that is that honestly that's
terrifying right it's like being pulled
over by a real police officer is super
terrifying what's more terrifying is
being pulled over by someone pretending
to be a professor and you know if if you
actually are pulled over you know the
headlights are shining into your car you
can't really see the car that's behind
you yeah or the the silhouetted figure
walking towards your driver's side
window right right I mean you know all
kidding aside I would be honestly
terrified if someone pulled me over and
it they were in plain clothes I'm not
even sure I could tell that they were
playing clothes I mean that is the very
definition of impersonating a police
officer and I imagine that is like a
very big crime oh yeah yeah I mean that
of all the things that we've talked
about impersonating a police officer can
easily be a felony and uh yeah do not do
that it's bad
and then uh finally I guess uh somewhat
more benign we have an exhaust cut out
that lets you avoid the muffler and yeah
so this goes in on your exhaust before
your muffler and there's a remote
control in the car a vacuum tube goes up
into the cabin and then add a click of a
button you can open a valve inside of
this to bypass the catalytic converters
and the muffler making your car uh dump
noxious gases but also makes a lot of
noise
straight pipe it's a tricky way to
straight pipe your car yeah and I mean
so that's that's clearly legal you can't
bypass your exhaust and uh it'd be
incredibly stupid if someone admitted to
having this device yeah on their car
like if someone admitted to having this
advice on multiple YouTube channels with
millions of subscribers that person
might be
dumb it's very
good lawyer luckily we have one you know
so if you want to see a whole bunch of
other illegal products and some not
illegal products that should be illegal
definitely check out our collaboration
video over on donut all right so let's
talk in a little bit more detail about
those radar detectors and Jammers
because I've been fascinated with these
things for years if you have a lead foot
and the habit of getting speeding
tickets you might have considered
getting a radar detector or Scrambler or
Jammer now what are these devices and
how do they work now a radar detector is
a device that detects a police radar
wave that the police use with radar guns
to measure the speed of passing Vehicles
detectors are only meant to warn the
driver that police are monitoring the
area they don't actually interfere with
radar signals and in the US it's not
illegal to use a radar detector unless
you're in Virginia or Washington DC
however in all states it's illegal to
use a radar detector in a commercial
vehicle weighing over ten thousand
pounds now why would that be well the
idea is it's extra dangerous for a
commercial vehicle to go above the speed
limit especially since they may be
hauling dangerous goods like oil and gas
or you know thousands and thousands of
pounds of products and some states have
regulations about where a radar detector
can be mounted in California for
instance it has to be mounted on the
dashboard now radar jammers on the other
hand have been around for many years but
they're usually illegal and here's how
they work there's a computer in police
radar guns that measures the
differential between the reflected radar
waves to calculate a vehicle's speed and
Jammers transmit a signal to overpower
the data sent from the car to the police
radar guns and the FCC regulates the
frequencies used in radar guns stating
quote no person shall willfully or
maliciously interfere with or cause
interference to any radio communications
of any station licensed or authorized by
or under this chapter operated by the
United States government and since
signal Jammers and scramblers are
capable of interfering with radio
communications the feds have made them
illegal now jamming devices cannot be
certified or authorized because their
primary purpose is to block or interfere
with authorized radio communications and
therefore their use would compromise the
Integrity of the nation's communication
infrastructure and of course another
obviously illegal product is a license
plate flipper there's no doubt they they
look cool they make you feel just like
James bonding number plates naturally
valued all countries now a license plate
flipper generally allows the driver to
temporarily flip and or hide their
license plate in order to avoid
detection from traffic cameras and toll
booths and you know police that are
chasing you and they can also help you
hide from Mobsters spies jealous lovers
all depending on what you're into now
needless to say these are completely
totally and unequivocally illegal though
admittedly there is another potentially
less nefarious reason for having a
license plate cover now we live in a
world where there seems to be
surveillance everywhere both online and
offline and automated license plate
readers known as alpers scan license
plates of parked cars or cars that are
in traffic when uploaded to a central
database they can track all the places
that a vehicle may turn up that means
that everything about your daily habits
could be tracked because this
information is out in the public now
sometimes this valuable information is
even sold to third parties like debt
collectors lenders insurance companies
and other Shady groups now California
legislators considered allowing people
to Simply cover their license plates
when parked and there was bipartisan
support for the measure but lobbyists
effectively killed the bill that means
that businesses still have the right to
mount alpers on vehicles and drive them
around the city taking photographs of
every license plate and that also means
that law enforcement agencies have the
ability to collect the same data from
your vehicle and in 2018 the Department
of Homeland Security updated its
policies to give ice the agency
responsible for immigration access to
license plate recognition databases and
civil Libertarians are right to be
concerned about this as of two years ago
the Atlantic reported that Vigilant a
company that amasses this information
had collected roughly 2.2 billion
license plate photos and was capturing
and permanently storing about 80 million
additional geotagged images per month
but let's talk about a product that I
was actually surprised is very illegal
because I see this one a lot especially
in the movies now fans of the insanely
popular movie franchise The Fast and the
Furious have been eager to buy nitrous
oxide kits to soup up their cars Racers
use these kids to give their cars a
boost in street races and on the track
and generally speaking of nitrous oxide
kit is generally safe if it's used for
15 seconds or less but does that mean
it's legal for you to pretend to be Vin
Diesel while driving well you can
legally shave your head but you cannot
use a nitrous oxide kit while publicly
driving race car drivers have the legal
right to use nitrous on the track and so
do private property owners when you're
driving on private property and nitrous
oxide is not a controlled substance you
can buy sell or transport it but when it
comes to street vehicles it depends on
the state and local laws California has
some of the strictest laws on vehicle
modifications in aftermarket parts and
it is absolutely illegal to have a
Nitrous system without a carb
certification installed on your street
vehicle in California some local
counties and municipalities do emissions
testing and a Nitrous system would
absolutely wreak havoc on that
particular test and Ohio is another
state that strictly regulates nitrous
oxide it's not legal to use nitrous in a
car in Ohio so if you buy a nitrous
oxide there you are required to sign a
form declaring that you know it's
illegal to use in the car the let's face
it if you install nitrous oxide on your
93 Honda Civic you're probably going to
end up like hoovie's garage anyway and
button
whoa
oh Jesus I just blew the motor
I just completely blew the motor then
getting back to some real James Bond
stuff I know that when you're dealing
with terrible traffic and horrible
drivers that the urge to deploy some
spikes and just blow up the tires of
everyone else's on the road it's a very
strong urge I regret to inform you that
is illegal now a Caltrop is a weapon
that has been around for some form for
thousands of years it's a passive weapon
that projects spikes in different
directions preventing horses camels
elephants and land vehicles from moving
forward the Ukrainian military has been
making good use of them lately and
doomsday preppers are eager to buy these
as they wait for the zombie deep state q
Anon covet apocalypse and even some car
modders have created secret compartments
that hide caltrops to be deployed
against you know your enemies that are
following you these kinds of devices are
completely illegal under a whole Myriad
of different general purpose laws but
many states have specific regulations
that make caltrops and tire spikes
illegal to use unless they are used by
law enforcement for incredibly obvious
reasons and Texas for example
specifically banned caltrops after drug
dealers started using them and in Texas
a person can be charged with a felony if
they intentionally or knowingly possess
manufacture transport repair or sell a
tire deflation device such as a Caltrop
so unless you heard law enforcement do
not use Tire spikes of any kind
thinking of which if you're not law
enforcement don't pretend to be law
enforcement and for that reason it is
illegal to use car strobe lights that
flash red and blue because it makes you
look like a police officer nonetheless
you can buy some of these products on
Amazon there's also all kinds of illegal
light products on Amazon as well and for
the most part buying a light that can be
mounted to a car truck isn't illegal for
purchase but all states have different
rules about which vehicles can use which
kind of lights for example in almost
every state only the police are allowed
to use blue and red lights on top of a
car in many states only emergency
vehicles can use red lights on top of
the car and some states restrict the
kind of flash patterns and then of
course there are tons of brightness
restrictions as well most of this means
that states don't allow auxiliary lights
that can be brighter than a car's
headlights or brake lights because you
don't want to be installing aftermarket
lights that blind the people in front of
you so I'm sorry to burst all of your
James Bond dreams but all of these
products are illegal in some way or
another so if you do install any of
these product products you're gonna need
a good lawyer